nothing will compare to the night life  isn't tonight  [Music]  nothing will compare to the nice that we  have shared together and you know what  I'm talking about tonight my name my  family name up there that's something I  used to get laughed at for dreaming of  so never let anyone tell you that you  can't accomplish your dream  those four letters on the back of that  Jersey or my wife's name my kids name my  father's name my grandfather's name  we're not just carrying on for another  generation but now daddy Jack we're up  there forever  [Music]  and you know what I'd like to think on  the front of that Jersey we can't see it  but we all know it's there h-e-a-t and  that's you guys  that's this city this organization so  we're all up there you're up there with  me too and I'm gonna tell you why  because when I was down and out when I  was still going through things you guys  showed me how to rebound so thank you  [Applause]